- I'm Allie.
- I'm Lexie.
- [Allie And Lexie] We're the Kaplan twins
and today we're going to be not identical.
- For the day.
- Being an identical twin,
it's like having a built in best friend.
- Yeah.
- We do everything together.
- We're always together.
- We're artists so we paint together.
- Right, we spend all day together.
We paint on the same canvas together.
I don't think we're ever really apart.
- We're never apart.
(violin music)
- We actually didn't know
- [Allie And Lexie] That
we were identical until,
like, two years ago.
- Yeah.
- It doesn't really work that way.
If you look alike, it's more
about the science behind it.
- We got the whole DNA test.
99.9% same DNA.
When we thought we were fraternal--
- My hair would be different.
- Yeah, we tried to be different.
- But since we realized we're identical
we've been trying to look more alike.
- Yeah, we definitely
like looking the same
and also it's just easier when
we get dressed in the morning
or we have somewhere to go,
she'll put on an outfit,
and I'll be like,
- [Allie And Lexie] Oh, that looks great.
- [Lexie] I'm gonna wear that.
- [Allie] Okay, I'm
gonna do the same thing.
- [Lexie And Allie] I
don't think this will
make us wish we looked different.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, fuck, wow.
I look like I should be taller.
- You look like you should--
- And wearing a leopard
coat with a martini.
- Yeah.
- And smoking a cigarette.
When we meet strangers on the
street, they're always like,
"Oh, are you guys identical?"
- [Lexie] Are you twins?
- [Allie] Because we always
talk at the same time.
We talk over eachother.
- [Lexie] And especially
when we look exactly alike.
- [Allie] And we're
wearing the same outfit.
- Oh, you're twins.
It's fun.
- Yeah.
- We love it.
- Now that we look different, right?
- Yeah.
- We're gonna go talk to some people
and see if they react.
- See if they think we're--
- If I saw them on the street,
I would think that that's
a mother and a daughter.
- She is a twin sister.
- Yes.
- She's my identical twin.
- It might be more strange
for us or I don't know
if we're talking at the
same time with strangers--
- [Lexie] Maybe it'll be weird.
They'll be like,--
- [Allie] They'll be confused.
- [Lexie] "These people are
really in-sync with each other."
- They're in sync, but
they look different.
I'm confused.
- Who are they, yeah.
The Kaplan twins.
- I'm not chanting that.
- Our relationship with our mom,
- [Allie] We're super close.
- [Allie And Lexie]
Sometimes she has a favorite.
- [Allie] It depends.
- I'm the favorite right now.
- I think when Mom sees
this she's gonna be like,--
- Like, "What?"
- I think we'll give her a heart attack.
- But a fun one.
- You're not excited
to meet the collector?
I don't know, maybe.
(laughing)
- Did it give us a mental trip?
- I feel like it must've
been, I don't know.
It was just kind of--
- Some moments were funny.
Some moments were really weird.
- Confusing.
- Yeah.
- So, a lot of emotions.
It was funny.
- It was very funny.
- [Allie] We tricked a couple people.
- I think we got away with it.
- I just want to look the same.
- No, I think we want to look the same.
- It just feels weird.
- It feels, yeah.
- The whole thing feels weird.
Time to become identical.
- Definitely time to become identical.
- So time.
- Yeah.
- Need it.
- Over it.
- Miss you.
Miss your face.
Miss my face on your face.
- [Allie And Lexie] Finally,
we're identical again.
- Oh, my God.
I forgot what you looked like.
- I forgot what I look like.
- Shh, let me stare at you for a second.
- I'm so happy.
- I'm so happy for you.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- That was fun, though.
- I know.
- But I'm back.
(clap)
(laugh)